[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hello Walter I'm Martin
are you well I'm fine yes good I am well
you're well okay
so our interesting topic today prays
together press together yes what does
that refer to
exactly what it says there pressed
together and we're going to find out who
must press together we must all press
together and why
so but before we get to that let's open
with the word of Prayer
I Heavenly Father we thank you that we
can do these discussions and we ask that
you please enlighten our minds guide the
discussion into the knowing that you
want us to bring forth in Jesus name
amen
there's so much confusion and so much
talking past each other
that it sometimes
can Verge on the very frustrating
foreign
perfectionism if we talk about
righteousness by faith if we talk about
these issues it almost seems as if
people think there are two sides that
see things from an opposite angle
where in actual fact righteousness by
faith does not negate obedience nor does
it imply a license to sin
exactly but some people see it that way
and perfectionism
does not necessarily need to negate
righteousness by faith if you can see
them in the light that they're supposed
to be presented
but as I say people climb on bandwagons
and then there are two camps
or maybe three or four
and never the crowd will meet
but we are depressed together we are
supposed to be
a group of people separated by the Lord
a Remnant with a specific message for
Humanity
a message that must Sprout not out of
any elevation on our part like we have
arrived the new guys better shape up or
ship out
but a message that reflects the
character of God
and his Longing To Save Humanity
so let's ask a question how do we deal
with the less than perfect in the church
well the answer I think is the same as
we deal with the less than perfect in
our family
so if we're a little bit sarcastic we
can say thank God my child is Wayward
now I can separate myself from him or
her and not be bothered with them any
longer after all their Wayward right
can I do that no
can't do that would you do that with the
child would you do that with a loved one
in the family would you do that to a
spouse would you would you do that no
no right maybe the L people that would
do it but it's not the right thing to do
then why do some people want to do it
with the members in the church aren't
they also part of the family of God it
is
I can concentrate on my own Perfection
and be glad I'm not like them really can
I do that am I really that perfect
is that what Moses or the prophets did
or did they identify with a sinful
people Moses identified so much that he
even said you can rather take my life
out of the book of life and let them go
forward blood me from the book of life
but let them live so this is a a very
sensitive topic within the church
and we need to press together we need to
come to an accord
that if you see it from a different
angle it doesn't mean that you have now
become an enemy
well let's start with a quote we are
nearing the end of Earth's history and
God calls upon all to lift the Standard
Bearing the inscription here or they
that keep the Commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus now we've talked
about that many many times
what is the faith of Jesus it is
everything that's recorded in the word
of God because that's why I recorded it
to show us what his faith is and what
God's way of thinking is right
so in other words we have to come into
harmony with the way that God thinks
and to emulate the faith of Jesus
it's not enough to have faith in Jesus
you need to emulate the faith of Jesus
now did Jesus Keep The Commandments yes
all of them all of them right
okay
he calls upon his people to work in
Perfect Harmony
he calls upon those engaged in our
medical work to unite with the ministry
is there a tendency to separate them yes
unfortunately within our church even
don't don't mention anything of this
nature we are just this or that or the
other we are concentrating on the
medical side
and people will look at us and they will
all immediately follow and become
Christians no it's sad because like
we've mentioned if you do it like that
there's no light
okay so you have to United with the
ministry if you separate the medical
work from the ministry
then you've cut off an arm
because upon the ministry to cooperate
with the medical missionary workers he
calls upon the church to take up their
appointed Duty holding up the standard
of true reform in their own territory
leaving the trend and experienced
workers to press on into new fields
no word is to be spoken to discourage
any for this Grieves the heart of Christ
and greatly pleases the adversary do we
spend a lot of time
discouraging each other
definitely criticizing each other you
see now just on that point you mentioned
that the medical missionary work can't
be without the ministry part and then
also in this quote the preacher the
minister cannot do it without the
medical part but how you do it is what
you've just mentioned okay but there's
more here there's also the faith of
Jesus and the Commandments of God and
everything is mixed into the statement
all need to be baptized with the holy
spirit all should refrain from centering
and disparaging remarks and draw near to
Christ that they may appreciate the
heavy responsibilities which the
co-workers with him are caring
press together press together are the
words of our divine instructor Unity is
strength this Union is weakness and
defeat but I have a feeling we have too
much disunity and therefore it seems
like we are suffering one defeat after
the other
cannot the church
unite under the bloodstained banner of
Prince Emmanuel
and with one voice proclaim the message
to A Dying World is that not possible
well it's supposed to that's what
actually the mission of the church
should be to together as one bring the
Three Angels message to the world
all right now if this church is a
hospital and the people in it are
basically
recovering from disease do they all have
the same disease
no no
well they do and that's called sin that
is the basis of it but I mean in a
physical sense in a hospital does
everybody have the same disease or
malady no no they don't they are
different maladies the one has this the
other one has that and if you link it to
sin there are different emphasis
does that make one better than the other
one no not because Sony sin and the
wages of sin is dead so we're all
terminally ill
and need Heavenly bomb
here's an article from or a quote from
the review and Herald 1908 these words
were clearly and forcibly spoken
confess your faults one to another pray
one for another that you may be healed
imagine if you're going to confess your
faults one to another that implies that
you have faults
well anyone that's without faults is
also a liar
all right now the Bible says confess
your faults one to another the new
translations of course change that to
sin
confess your sins but sins are to be
confessed to God Alone exactly because
that is between you and God but your
faults
I have this this temperament whatever it
is I have this propensity to whatever it
is
can you pray for me that I can overcome
this or whatever we can talk about that
but we don't have to go into meticulous
detail
and that is between you and God and then
again press together press together
and love as Brethren pray together
the Lord has paid the price of his own
blood for the Salvation of the world he
suffered every indignity that men could
devise and Satan could invent
in order to carry out the Plan of
Salvation
let not the teacher seek to exalt self
but let him see the necessity of
learning of Christ daily and making him
the pattern
for the teachers and the students our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ should be
the only example
so in other words don't exalt a human
being
look at the standard
because there's only one standard worth
emulating
bear in mind that the Lord will accept
as teachers only those who will be
gospel teachers
a great responsibility rests upon those
who attempt to teach the Lost gospel
message isn't that the whole church
every single person in the church
everybody yes no matter what your
position within the church right every
single one they are to be laborers
together with God in the training of
human Minds the teacher who fails to
keep the Bible standard always before
him misses an opportunity of being a
laborer together with God in giving to
the mind the mold that is essential for
a place in the Heavenly courts so Martin
how important is example
vary and also the the eggs like you said
the example and that that comes out of
your mouth
if it it has to be the same
all right so we have to have some
practical
ideas here as to how we can press
together
because there are so many Winds of
Doctrine blowing in the church
and so many compromises with the world
and compromise us with sin
what the Bible called sin seems to be no
longer exceedingly sinful no and it's
sometimes mainly because they want to be
politically correct well eating that
that forbidden fruit it seems such a
small thing
but the consequences you had a sermon on
that once remember such a small little
thing just taking a bite from a fruit
and the consequences
uh
Indescribable Indescribable just look at
the news and you'll see the consequences
so an example is very very important
and then you have this question of the
dichotomy
and this question of come out and be
separate
and there's so much controversy about
the dichotomy and there's so much
controversy about coming out and being
separate because the argument goes if
you separate yourself how you're going
to reach anyone
isn't that what they said it's yeah it's
such an illogical question but that is
what people ask and they love to quote
Paul where he says I become all things
for all men to the Jew I become a Jew
for the Greek I become a Greek so I will
join you in your sin just to reach you I
can go to the bar and I drink a beer
with you because I'm trying to reach you
then we can link up and we can have
something in common and they ignore all
the statements where he lists everything
that must no longer be done hmm
all right
First Kings 8 53 for thou did separate
them from amongst the people of the
earth to be thine inheritance
as our Speakers by the hand of Moses thy
servant when thou broadest our fathers
out of Egypt O Lord God separated them
separation is something that doesn't sit
well with many echomanism is the
watchword for the world today not
separation
in fact the papacy go so far as to
condemn the so-called separatists
definitely we've shown that numerous
times all right
let's jump to the New Testament second
Corinthians being not unequally yoked
together with unbelievers for what
Fellowship has righteousness with
unrighteousness and what communion has
light with Darkness isn't that exactly
the same thing all right what about the
next verse
and what Concord has Christ with Belial
or what part has he that believeth with
an infidel
and what agreement has the temple of God
with Idols for ye are the Temple of the
Living God as God has said I will dwell
in them and walk in them and I will be
their God and they shall be my people is
he rooting his faith here in the Old
Testament yes
who's speaking here by the way
Paul is speaking here okay and he's
reiterating everything at the Old
Testament says about it right no so it's
going to be hard if they say the Old
Testament is not suitable anymore and
then he quotes
from First Kings wherefore come out from
amongst them and be ye separate says the
Lord and touch not the unthink clean
thing and I will receive you and I will
be a father unto you and you shall be my
sons and daughters says the Lord
Almighty now separation does that mean
isolation no because that's where the
Crux comes in
separation does not equate with
isolation because the Israelites did the
Isolation part especially when Christ
was came to this earth all right and
once you start isolating you miss the
point because God came to save sinners
and if he if he saved you
that means he wants to save the next guy
too yeah important
okay so it's not an individual
um act once you're saved now then you
have to help others as well okay
so we need to find a way to press
together but we need a right way to
press together it has to be based on
truth it has to be based on the faith of
Jesus it cannot be based on secularism
or it cannot be based on social issues
it must be based on the faith of Jesus
right yes okay
so he calls us out of the world
but he doesn't call us out of the church
so we must be aware of herd splitters
with a little herd here and a little
herd there
you must get from their tents
Cora was a hurt splitter
Cora said
you know this is not right why should
Moses be the one who through whom God
Converses we are all holy
and they found out
that that was a very dangerous road to
travel
okay
so if we go to Hebrews chapter 10 and we
read a few verses there it says let us
draw near with the True Heart in full
Assurance of Faith having our hearts
sprinkled from an evil conscience and
our bodies washed with pure water is
that is there a cleansing involved here
you have to you have to get rid of
whatever is defiling you okay okay
let us out fast the profession of our
faith without wavering for he is
faithful that promised
and let us consider one another to
provoke unto love and to Good Works not
forsaking the assembling of ourselves
together
as the manner of some is but exhorting
one another and so much the more as you
see the day approaching
isn't there a tendency to separate
ourselves more and more well if you if
you look at what's happening
in our church today we can see that
Satan is very busy
now some people say that I say you must
put super glue on your posterior and
they say well how can I sit in a church
that uh does the exact opposite of
everything
that the spirit of Prophecy says
now I never said that you must sit in a
church that does the exact opposite and
have to suffer through these things
but you don't leave the body that's what
I refer to
eventually it might come down to having
home churches
but the idea is that we have to try and
press together but you can only press
together if you're like-minded that's it
you know and coming to the home churches
that you speak about
have you really tried
all that you can at your local church
Martin that is a very important point
because they're a family right
and some of the children might be away
with
but you don't give up if they if they
provoke you and tell you that you're not
wanted you don't force yourself upon
them
but as long as there is an an opening
wedge you continue
and I always remember that story when I
was in one of our big university
campuses
and it was very Rowdy the meeting with
drums and everything that is with it
and I gave a message
at that University there was
probably pretty straight
and one of the elderly pastors came to
me afterwards and it was very tearful
and he thanked me
and then he told me how he hangs around
and has private little discussions
because people are swept into a
direction by peer pressure
reminds me of that occasion that I had
in in Europe once
where the youth were gathering and it
was like a rock concert and I've told
that story many times
and I found this one little guy who said
I can't be in there because my Jesus is
not in there so we had this discussion
and that discussion grew and in the end
they were you know
a whole host of people that were of the
same mindset but were you know
constrained by peer pressure yes because
that's what I mean also with it
I I'm very sure
they are other people in all churches
that feel the same as you
so find them remember God also wants
everybody in that church even apostate
churches yes to still be saved I know
you've got to work in there I know some
Churches where uh the Sabbath school for
example
breaks up into groups
and you will find one group that is a
little bit more conservative and you'll
find another group that is more liberal
and eventually if the conversation is is
deep enough
the groups will grow
even within churches
but we have to press together and not
forsake the Assembly of ourselves
because no man is an island we need each
other and just to clarify by we what
we've said now we're not condoning any
apostasy in a church no no
but we have the message to the loudest
sins God is leading out a people
he has a chosen people a church on the
earth whom he has made the depositories
of his lawyers committed to them sacred
trust and eternal truth to be given to
the world
he would reprove and correct them the
message to the loudest sins is
applicable to Seventh-Day Adventists who
have had great light and have not walked
in the light
it is those who have made great
profession but have not kept in step
with their leader that will be spewed
out of his mouth unless they repent the
message to pronounce The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church Babylon and call the
people of God out of her
does not come from any Heavenly
messenger or any human agent inspired by
the spirit of God
the true witness says I counsel thee to
buy of me gold tried in the fire
that there may be rich and white raiment
that thou mayest be clothed and that the
shame of thy nakedness do not appear and
anoint thine eyes with eyes solve and
that that thou may see does this
describe a church that is perfect no not
at all
so maybe I can direct a question to you
because we get this a lot
people say okay but we don't call the
Church Babylon but we call the structure
of leadership Babylon
all right my question is is the
structure of leadership part and parcel
of the church yes are there people in
the structure of leadership that are
conservative yes are there people in the
structure of the church that are liberal
yes are there people in the church that
fit in any category in between yes are
there people in the structure of
leadership that tend to be economical
yes are there people in the structure of
the church that weepen between the Altar
and the ports because they are not
economical definitely all right so I
would tend not to separate any part of
this body
and say that is where the problem lies
the problem is right across the board
from the highest level to the lowest
level
and everybody whether they are in the
general conference whether they are in a
union whether they are in a conference
whether they are in a church board
whether they are in the pews
has exactly the same admonition buy from
me gold okay but now that what you've
just said how do we bring that into
tithing
is it right for people to say okay I do
not agree with what this people these
people in this leadership are doing with
the tithes and then withhold my tithe
or put it somewhere else all right now
did God tell you to judge
or did he say that all judgment is his
all Jasmine is here did he tell you to
bring the tithe into the storehouse yes
did he all right are there people that
are on board with the Three Angels
message in leadership yes and are there
people that seem to be averse to the
idea yes all right so if you cut it
then somebody is going to suffer is it
possible that one group would be
disadvantaged possibly over another
group definitely all right so why don't
you leave that to God Martin well
there's another one that I'd like to ask
I get these questions so I have to get
some answers on it but what about
the Levites when they were apostate that
Israel still have to give their tithing
oh yes they they actually came and took
it of course it didn't stop there and
maybe we can just clarify that there's
certain structure in The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church what is the god of
order right yes and he put in place a
structure of how tithing in this church
has to be spent but he also puts the
structure of how leadership is to
exercise leadership there may be no
lording that doesn't make them Gods
within the church definitely not and
they have no greater say than the member
who only sits on the Pew they have no
greater say and they have no greater
standing with God either
we are all in exactly the same boat
exactly and just to make it then clear
it's not that easy to miss use the
tithing
maybe the offerings can be a little bit
misapplied but this is a very strict
structure when it comes to Target yeah
so that's I just wanted to put it out
there because we got many questions
about people asking us on this well my
answer would always be what does the
Lord say
storms whatever he says that's the best
way to follow
as many as I love I rebuke and Jason be
zealous therefore and repent behold I
stand at the door and knock If any man
hear my voice
and open the door I will come into him
and will sup with him and he with me is
there any coercion here not at all
there's a knocking yes
but there's no coercion he doesn't open
the door he doesn't force you to open
that you have to open it right
to him that overcometh will I grant to
sit with me in my throne even as I also
overcame and sat down with my father in
his throne you know it's very easy to go
and sit on a throne
it's far more difficult to sit in a
throne
if you said in a throne that means your
part and parcel of the decision-making
you are locked in
you're not sitting on it and throw a
tantrum and get off again you are part
and parcel of the decision making and
that's how inclusive God is it's
actually amazing you know what Martin
this deity that we're dealing with over
here
has not one iota of coercion in him and
not nothing of selfishness and it's all
inclusive
I know of no other deity in any
religious system
that has this character no
you take away God has a council
when he sits with the with all the
representatives of the world and he
counsels them he's Sovereign he's
all-knowing he's got everything but he's
still includes everybody it's amazing
he's an amazing God that we serve
all right now what about the prophets
they all identified with sinful Israel
they never separated themselves and said
well why don't you follow me in my
beautiful example right
I think Paul said it once but he said it
in tongue-in-cheek
Nehemiah says the words of Nehemiah the
son of hakaliah and it came to pass in
the months of chisler in the 12th year
as I was in shushan the palace
that hanani one of my brethren came he
and certain men of Judah and I asked
them concerning the Jews that had
escaped which were left of the Captivity
and concerning Jerusalem
and they said unto me the remnant that
are left of the Captivity there in the
province are in great Affliction and
reproach
the wall of Jerusalem also is broken
down and the gates thereof are burnt
with fire
so the remnant is in great Affliction
and reproach can we identify yeah it's
typological
the wall of Jerusalem is broken down
that means the law is no more right
because that's what the world stands for
and it came to pass when I heard these
words that I sat down and wept and
mourned certain days and fasted and
prayed before the god of Heaven
and I said I beseech thee O Lord God Of
Heaven the great and terrible God that
keep us Covenant and mercy for them that
love him and observe his Commandments
that portion is always there right and
every prophet
every prophet let time here now be
attentive and Thine Eyes Open that thou
amazed hear the prayer of thy servant
which I pray before thee now day and
night for the children of Israel thy
servants
and confess the sins of the children of
Israel which
we have sinned against thee both I and
my father's house have
seven
is that inclusive no definitely huh
Martin
we can learn a lot from this country
We have dealt very corruptly against
thee
and have not kept the Commandments nor
the statutes nor the judgments which
thou commanded thy servant Moses okay
Martin how fussy are we really as a
denominative people
in terms of The Commandments of God well
are there elements of compromise that
are creeping in it's definitely there's
compromise creeping in and is the world
exerting its influence on us definitely
the compromise is actually because of
worldly influence okay so if you take
things like the seventh commandment
is in the world we have great compromise
we even have legislation which legalizes
what the Bible condemned yes
and then we have we have this attitude
of you know we cannot be condemning
therefore we need to embrace it
is sin Martin finished
that's so important you can love the
person and help him through it but you
still have to point out the sin not the
point of start the sin because the wages
of sin is dead that's it cannot condone
it so we cannot run with the compromises
on the seventh Commandment that are
being introduced into the world even in
the in the legislature
we must be separate and say sorry what
is happening in the world is sin
We have dealt very corruptly against
thee and have not kept the Commandments
nor the statutes nor the judgments which
thou commandest thy servant Moses take
the first commandment
that very specific deity that took you
out of Egypt that's the one that you may
serve and have no other gods beside him
is it possible in an ecumenical setting
or in an inter-religious setting to
adhere to the first commandment no
because you've got other religions that
do not adhere to that at all right let's
just take a Christian denomination and
say every aspect that is mentioned in
the Bible about the seventh commandment
which includes everything from
relationship between a man and a woman
and a man and a man and a woman and a
woman
all of it how strictly do we adhere to
what the Bible actually says or are we
compromising oh are we compromising on
every level right
so we need to know that we have to stand
for something and we have to be separate
and give a note of warning and we must
acknowledge that we've been at fault
and we have been at fault and we have
personally also transgressed
remember I beseech Thee the word that
thou commandest thy servant Moses saying
if ye transgress I will scatter you
abroad amongst the Nations but if you
turn unto me and keep my Commandments
and do them
though they were of You cast out unto
the uttermost parts of the heaven yet
will I gather them from thence and will
bring them into the place that I have
chosen to set my name there there is to
be a gathering
a gathering to what
to press together to keep the
Commandments to keep the Commandments so
we have to call the people out of the
world and show them that they have to
keep the Commandments right does that
negate righteousness by faith no not at
all it Embraces it ah well said Martin
now these are thy servants and thy
people whom thou Hast Redeemed by thy
great power and by thy strong hand O
Lord I beseech thee let now thine ear be
attentive to the prayer of thy servant
and to the prayer of thy servants who
desire to fear thy name and prosper I
pray thee thy servant this day and Grant
him Mercy in the sight of this man for I
was the king's cup Bearer
we have sinned with our fathers we have
committed iniquity we have done wickedly
are we prepared to do that as a
denomination I think it's time
I don't know if we prepared yet but we
have to get there we have to get there
right if we do not get there we're not
going to go through we're not going to
go through we're not going to be part of
those that bring the loud cry
the Lord is well pleased for his
righteousness sake he will magnify the
law
and make it honorable wasn't this is so
clear
and people say well the Law's been done
away with therefore this is obsolete it
cannot be obsolete that's that's
ridiculous I we I had a discussion today
with a young girl in in a class in a um
and she's about 14 years old
and when we were talking about people
saying that the Old Testament
is actually has to be done away with and
even the law no what no longer applies
and she said there and she said but
that's not logical
and she's 14 years old I said to her you
know what maybe some people must desire
a brain transplant that's a thing so
she and and we were talking about it
we've been talking about it as well and
she said as logic left everybody and
that's exactly the problem
it's so logically logical if you read
the Bible
it's impossible to get rid of the law
and the Old Testament
all right so let's read that again the
Lord is well pleased for his
righteousness sake
he will magnify the law and make it
honorable can you separate the law from
the righteousness of Christ
no
what does righteousness mean doing right
what defines doing right
keeping the law the law defines it but
this is the people robbed and spoiled
they are all of them snared in holes and
they are HID in prison houses they offer
a prey and none delivereth for a spoil
and none says restore that's our
condition
Martin we have to get back to the point
where we realize the essence what was it
that struck you
when you discovered
the message
of this remnant
wasn't it the fact that you were a
transgressor of the law everything that
I thought was right was wrong
exactly and when I discovered that the
law had been changed and that I'd been
living in transgression of the Lord
shocked me
and I started research and I discovered
everything else the Antichrist this that
and the other righteousness by faith a
whole Gambit but it got to the point
where I realized I was living in
transgression of the law
and I was totally lost you know and it's
time to realize that we have sinned it
it includes you
absolutely you cannot say my church my
church that church all of these people
now we can we dare not be robbed and
spoiled by every wind of modern
Evangelical Doctrine right
in chapter 42 23 onward says who amongst
you will give ear to this who will
hearken and hear for the time to come
who gave Jacob for a spoil and Israel to
the robbers
did not the Lord he against whom we have
sinned
for they would not walk in his ways
neither were they obedient unto his law
so the lord gave them over like Paul
says he handed them over to Satan
and then they howled hmm
but why because they had walked contrary
to the Lord therefore he has poured upon
him the fury of his anger and the
strength of battle and it has set him on
fire round about yet he knew not and it
burnt him yet he laid it not too hot
stubbornness right
I think that's one of the main problems
oh Lord
though our iniquities testify against us
do thou it for thy name's sake for our
backslidings are many and we have sinned
against thee this describes the
condition
of the church and whether we're talking
about Nehemiah whether we're talking
about Isaiah whether we're talking about
Jeremiah it's always inclusive language
we have sinned
it's a it's amazing to see this
what about Daniel Daniel identified with
these people he also said we sinned
Daniel 9 verse 5 we have sinned and have
committed iniquity and have done
wickedly in every belt even by departing
from thy precepts and from thy judgment
is this a recurring theme modern
it's right through and there's a thread
running yeah
oh Lord to us belong us confusion of
Faith to our Kings to our princes to our
fathers because
we have sinned against thee all Israel
have transgressed thy law even by
departing that they might not obey thy
voice therefore the curse is poured upon
us and the oath that is written in the
law of Moses the servant of God because
we have sinned against him
and now O Lord Our God thou has brought
thy people forth out of the land of
Egypt with the mighty hand and has
gotten the Renown as to this day we have
sinned we have done wickedly maybe I can
just say for in case somebody has not
caught on yet
this is also talking about
us the church it's talking about us
absolutely now Martin how does this
affect righteousness by faith I'm
tempted to go
to go off
of topic
may I go off time well we're good at it
are we good at it
you know let's go to Romans chapter 10.
and you know
Romans is an amazing book right it's the
one that got the Reformation going yeah
it can be a very
misunderstood a very misunderstood book
as well all right so we have to look at
that as well so perhaps we can go a
little bit further I don't know
chapter 10 Brethren my heart's desire
and prayer to God for Israel is that
they might be saved
were they living in apostasy yes but his
heart's desires that they should be
saved should that be our heart's desire
that's it all right so let's just say
Brethren my heart's desire for the
church The Seventh-Day Adventist
churches that they might be saved could
I read it like that yes
okay
if I bear them the record that they have
Zeal for God but not according to
knowledge
foreign
for they being ignorant of God's
righteousness and going about to
establish their own righteousness have
not submitted themselves unto the
righteousness of God
any effort
any means of trying to establish your
own righteousness by striving to keep
the law
it's futile
does that mean I must not strive to keep
the law no
and this is where we talk past each
other and that's it we talk past each
other all the time on this issue if you
stand for righteousness by faith then
you have opened the door
and you've said to the Lord please come
in and clean this mess up because God is
not going to sit down with you in a
messy room no which is your heart he's
going to clean it out and he's going to
eat with you and the food on the table
is going to be clean food and it's going
to be decent food and everything is
going to be right right you're not going
to pop the cork no when the Lord is in
the heart right when he's sitting at
your supper table if you would do that
for an Earthly King how much more so for
a Heavenly King so let's not
misunderstand it I cannot clean it up
God must clean it up I cannot live it
but he can live it in me all I have to
do is say yes the end result is total
obedience to the Commandments of God
that's it
and if you say but I believe in
righteousness
then they say oh so you mean you're you
can remain a sinner and you're covered
that's ridiculous argument I don't even
understand how people can can reason
like that if you accept the
righteousness of Christ
then you come automatically into harmony
with the law that's it
okay and then it's a walk
for Christ is the end of the law for
righteousness to everyone that believeth
is the end of the law okay so the law is
gone now the law is gone I believe in
Jesus his blood is over me I don't have
to keep the law now why does Paul bring
it back in chapter 14. so obviously
somebody's confused right exactly
so it's the Fulfillment of the law it's
the ultimate culmination of the law he's
the ultimate example of what it is to
live the law he's the reason I can use
him his righteousness to be saved for
Moses describeth the righteousness which
is of the law
that the man which does those things
shall live by them in other words you
have to keep the Commandments were they
very good at it no because they didn't
do it by faith could they be better yes
okay
but the righteousness which is of faith
speaketh in this wise
say not in thine heart who shall Ascend
into heaven that is to bring Christ down
from above
or who shall descend into the deep that
is to bring up Christ again from the
dead
Paula's away with words that can really
confuse you right
but what says it the word is neither
even in thy mouth and in thy heart that
is the word of faith which we preach
that if Thou shalt confess with thy
mouth that the Lord the Lord Jesus and
Shall Believe in thine heart that God
has raised him from the dead Thou shalt
be saved all right so I have to do
nothing else I just have to believe that
Jesus was raised from the dead and that
he is the one that is Lord and I'm saved
no that's not what he was saying okay
now what does it mean
say not in thine heart who shall Ascend
into heaven
or who shall descend into the deep
that is to bring up Christ again from
the dead there are two ways in which
Humanity
tries to emulate what is right
even without Christ right
one is to exalt self
to the level of Christ yeah
so you exalt yourself and say I'm saved
I'm like him I'm a Child of God
I'm saved
I am saved or I am of the of the tribe
of Benjamin I'm from the line of Abraham
I am saved because I have this lineage
the other one is to bring Christ down to
your level
and to say all right
I can do it
because I've defined that Christ is at
exactly my level
but where's the Benchmark who is The
Benchmark he here's the Benchmark now
how high is the benchmark
too high for us to attain so you won't
be able to jump no you won't be able to
jump over it you're gonna miss so what
is the solution to bring bring the bar
down so if you can jump over it's always
easier or to lift yourself up to such a
level that you can actually just walk
over it right
both of them are totally futile and
useless
and we have both groups in the church
yeah those that exalt themselves to the
level of Christ I can do it because he
promised
and those that bring him down to our
level
well after all
he sat with publicans and sinners so I
can do the same right that's what they
say oh well that's the thinking okay but
the Benchmark is so high
it's the righteousness of Christ
therefore I can never attain it the only
one who can attain it is he working
through me and in me
does that mean I must have the fruits of
it yes
because if I don't have the fruits then
he's not in me
is that right yeah for sure okay it's
impossible to if your fruits are wrong
then obviously
it's a slap in the face or then you what
like you just said then you brought
Christ down to your level yeah for with
the heart man believeth unto
righteousness and with the mouth
confesses is made unto salvation for the
scripture says whosoever believeth on
him shall not be ashamed for there is no
difference
between the Jew and the Greek for the
same Lord over all is Rich unto all that
call upon him he is our Salvation there
is no way that I can be without him if I
turn to chapter 11 verse 1 it says I say
then has God Cast Away his people
God forbid
for I also am an Israelite of the Seed
of Abraham of The Tribe of Benjamin and
then he talks about all of these things
and he says you know they can be grafted
back in but there's a condition
um
they have to be in Christ
because they cut themselves off the VIN
the Vine
they were grafted they were cut out they
were pruned out because they didn't
believe that he was the one that was
going to do what is impossible for them
to do by themselves so we must be
careful not to get in a position that we
have to be cut off by Christ correct
because we are actually wild branches
that were grafted in
so if the original branches were to
accept the righteousness of Christ and
they could be grafted in as well did
Paul understand the typology of the Old
Testament oh yeah even that's why
sometimes for us it seems like he's
writing very difficult because he
understood it very well if we go to
chapter 13 and we skip the first part
and we go to verse 8 which is a new
paragraph in the original
it says oh no man anything but to love
one another
for he that loveth another has fulfilled
the law
for this Thou shalt not commit adultery
Thou shalt not kill Thou shalt not steal
Thou shalt not bear false witness Thou
shalt not covet and if there be any
other commandment it is briefly
comprehended in this saying name namely
Thou shalt love thy neighbor as thyself
in other words he's saying love to your
neighbor is a summary of the law
has he done away with the law no he's
embraced it right absolutely
love worketh no ill to his neighbor
therefore love is the fulfilling of the
law so if you do not show love
and compassion for the erring
then you are a law breaker
is that correct mark 100 all right this
is scary I'm not going to go further
breakdown but that's so true you see
that the problem is people we don't know
old
um discussion on this but people
misunderstand love
they misunderstand it and that's why
they say that the law is done away with
because they see the law as there's no
love in it and in actual fact that is
the transcript of God's love it is the
embodiment of love
he was he was running through the second
table of the decalogue there right
and he was listing them all and he said
this is the basis of love
and here it was Daniel and he said that
we have sinned we have done wickedly not
one of us can boast
the only righteousness that we can have
ever is the righteousness of Christ and
then also we have to thank him every
single day thank you for giving us that
righteousness that we can
now here Paul is writing to Timothy and
he said this is a faithful saying and
worthy of all acceptation
that Christ Jesus came into the world to
save sinners
of whom I am chief
did he identify himself with his with
his people he definitely didn't stand
there and say you and you and you I'm
the chief and I always said we're going
to have it out in heaven because
he has no right to this title of being
the chief of Sinners I have a privilege
and I'm thinking you might think you
have that privilege well everybody we
must know so certain people came from
James first they embraced them then they
stabbed them in the back and when James
kephus and John who seemed to be pillars
perceived the grace that was given unto
me they gave to me and Barnabas the
right hand of Fellowship that we should
go unto the Heathen and they unto the
circumcision
only they would that we should remember
the poor the same which I also was
forward to do but
when Peter came to Antioch I was stood
him to his face because he wants to be
blind was there an argument in that
early church
there was a few arguments definitely
a church that received outpouring the
Holy Spirit wasn't perfect
no they had their friction and problems
but they did one thing
they pressed together all right if you
go to Philippians 3 verse 3 for we are
the circumcision which worship God in
spirit and rejoice in Christ Jesus and
have no confidence in the flesh
how much confidence do you have in your
capacity
to withstand sin
well as soon as you try it you get
disappointed very quickly you thought
you slip on that proverbial banana peel
right so we must have no confidence in
the flesh but can we have confidence in
Christ
all our confidence has to be in him all
right so we must be aware of the
circumcision which rules the end rules
there the wheat and the tears grow
together the church
it's not perfect it's a hospital
holding fast the faithful word as he has
been taught that he may be able by sound
Doctrine both to exhort and to convince
the gained Sayers for there are many
unruly and vain talkers and deceivers
especially they of the circumcisions
whose mouth Must Be Stopped to subvert
whole houses teaching things which they
ought not for filthy Luca's sake
are these people there from the
beginning yeah so will they be that then
definitely are you going to separate
yourself you can separate and then you
start your own little thing here and
eventually inside of that one that
you've started you'll have the same
problem all right so let's get back to
business
we have to be perfect
but we have to have the Perfection of
Christ right
but we must be aware of perfectionism
now there are some people that will go
so far as to say Paul wasn't there yet
he hadn't attained yet not that I have
already attained he said but later he
attained so we can also attain where
does it say ever that he attained so
Paul is the one who spoke about the
transformation at the final Trump right
and the spirit of Prophecy says not
until this vile body
has been changed unto his glorious body
can we say that we are
without sin yes does that mean
that we should still be sinning as some
people then claim no
you must still strive
to be sinless
with Christ's righteousness helping you
and him helping you like we've said
before the alcoholic
that stops drinking
doesn't stop being an alcoholic he is
just in remission
he has stopped
and he is using his willpower and God is
assisting him so that he can overcome
that weakness and so he no longer drinks
and the same with sin if you're addicted
to something pornography you close that
port and you stop
that doesn't mean that your nature won't
war against you no but you will not
submit your nature because you have
attached yourself to a higher power
so the Youth of our time may become as
precious in the sight of God as was
Samuel
by Faithfully maintaining their
Christian Integrity they may exert a
strong influence in the work of reform
such men are needed at this time God has
a work for every one of them never did
man achieve greater results for God and
Humanity
then may be achieved in this our day by
those who will be faithful to their
god-given trust
is that same power available
today that was working in the life of
Samuel yes so that power has been
available in the since Adam okay now
what example
did he have
by the from the priests
not a good one was Eli a good example no
no he was indulgent right yeah
and where his son's a good example no no
not at all no so he was like Daniel
living in the midst of sin
but without spot yeah okay why is it
that so many claim to be holy and
sinless it is because they are so far
from Christ
I've never dared to claim any such thing
from the time that I was 14 years old if
I knew what the will of God was I was
willing to do it you never have heard me
say I'm sinless
those that get sight of the loveliness
and exalted character of Jesus Christ
who was holy and lifted up and his train
fills the temple will never say it
yet we are to meet with those that will
say such things more and more
modern does this statement say that you
will continue sinning
no
but it says that you can't say that you
are sinless exactly so Martin how do you
reconcile this statement with the idea
that you should not sin
you should not sin you might have a
propensity but you have to embrace
Christ to help you to not go that route
ah so if people say if you believe this
then you run into the trouble of saying
all right we will keep on sinning until
the end now we will have a sinful nature
until the end
but we need not sin
in fact you should not sin go and sin no
more if it were not possible for you to
do that then Christ could not have given
that commandment right definitely and
you see that's where I think there's a
whole war going on between this in the
the people that say you have to be now
they're talking past each other that's
what you've been saying that's what I'm
saying press together press together
just because you're looking at it from
this angle and somebody else is looking
at it from this angle doesn't mean we
have to talk past each other the idea is
we must Embrace obedience to God's
Commandments we must live without sin
but we cannot say that we are sinless
because we have a sinful nature and a
sinful propensity but we do not have to
act upon it who is going to give us
power not to act upon it only Jesus I
all right I want to say
to whomsoever the glory of God has been
revealed you will never have the least
inclination to say I'm holy I'm
sanctified
let God write it in his books if he will
but you should never utter it and there
is the Crux and Martin I've heard
evangelicals preach that you may never
say what is written over there one of
them was Shula
he says the very worst thing that you
can do is to call someone a sinner a man
is no longer with us but the Evangelical
way of thinking is the exact opposite of
this
we cannot say I'm sinless
until when
tell this vile body is changed and
fashioned like unto his glorious body
that happens at the Lost prompt is this
a license to sin no you see this is the
way we talk past each other this is no
license to sin this is an acknowledgment
of our dependence and our weakness but
if we constantly seek to follow Jesus
the Blessed Hope Is Ours of standing
Before the Throne of God without spot or
wrinkle or any such thing complete in
Christ roped in his righteousness and
Perfection that's your only hope that's
it the only way you can have without
spot or wrinkle is that white robe of
ease
it is not essential for you to know and
tell others all the whys and wherefores
as to what constitutes the new heart
or as to the position they can and must
reach so as never to sin you have no
such work to do modern it is not my job
for me to tell you what constitutes the
new heart or the position that you must
reach
so as never to sin it's not my job but
some people make it their job
my job is to preach the gospel
and the gospel is very simple
Humanity Has Fallen
Has Fallen
it is in a fallen state it is hopelessly
lost all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of God nobody has the capacity
to pull themselves out of the Quagmire
but thanks be to God there is one who
can and that is Jesus Christ the sinless
Spotless Son of God
that came to this earth and made it
possible
by living a sinless life dying for my
transgression rising from the grave and
if I am prepared to die with him then
I'm also privileged to be raised with
him and and live in newness of Life
which he empowers me to do
But Me In My Own Strength I am weak and
have a sinful nature
to which I may not respond any longer
because it is not I that live but he
that lives in me
is that clear or is that mud that's
clear are you sure yes
okay
so we have no such work to do the work
of hammering out your character
has been never been given to me it's
only the work of Christ
what has been given to us is to identify
what sin is preach obedience to the
Commandments
identifying that we are all lost and
pointing to the solution that's our job
that's it
Paul states to Timothy this is a
faithful saying and worthy of all
acceptation that Christ Jesus came into
the world to save Sinners of whom I am
chief all right we've had this before
but we'll just reiterate it all the
prophets
identified themselves in this manner all
of them
he writes in Philippians chapter 3
finally my brethren rejoice in the Lord
to write the same things to you to me
indeed is not Grievous
but for you it is safe beware of dogs
beware of evil workers beware of
concision
so we don't want any
thing that divides beware of it is there
much division in our ranks and has it
actually gotten worse in the past few
years it certainly doesn't seem to me as
though it has improved no it's it's it's
getting worse so who's working the devil
right
for we are the circumcision which
worship God in spirit and rejoice in
Christ Jesus and have no confidence in
the flesh
as soon as you start having confidence
in your flesh as soon as you start
preaching that this is what you must
attain and this is what you must achieve
and this is how you must be perfect then
you are developing confidence in the
flesh
our only confidence is in Christ
though I might have confidence in the
flesh if any other man thinkers that he
has wherewith he might Trust In the
Flesh I'm all and then he lists
everything
and he counts it for rubbish
I love the way he wrote it is it sounds
like
Solomon yes the conclusion of the matter
he says well let me show you how cool I
am I was circumcised on the eighth day
I'm of the stock of Israel of The Tribe
of Benjamin a Hebrew of Hebrews touching
the law I'm a Pharisee concerning Zeal I
was persecuting the church touching
righteousness which of the law blameless
I did everything but what things were
gained to me those I can't lost for
Christ
it's rubbish
ye dartless and I count all things but
lust for the Excellency of the knowledge
of Christ Jesus my Lord for whom I have
suffered the loss of all things
and to count them for done
that I might win Christ
all of that all of his works all of his
Zeal all the things that you attained
can you make it anywhere
that's about as low as it goes right
and be found in him not having mine own
righteousness which is of the law but
that which is through the Faith of
Christ the righteousness which is of god
by faith Martin has he lowered the bar
or has he raised it he raised it he
showed you where the bar is and that's
Christ so his best effort was done yeah
that I may know him and the power of his
resurrection and the fellowship of his
sufferings being made conformable unto
his death
if by any means am I detained to the
resurrection of the dead that's our only
hope Martin you see now if some people
can get discouraged
the bar is so high but Christ makes it
possible that's why he said you must
have faith in his righteousness what is
the New Covenant that the law is where
written in the heart because obviously
when it was not written in the heart
it was done
right or your achievements in terms of
keeping it was done
and then he makes the statement which so
many say well you know maybe he wasn't
ready yet when he wrote this not as
though I had already attained
either were already perfect but I follow
after thee if that I may apprehend that
for which I am apprehended of Christ
Jesus Brethren I count not myself to
have apprehended
but this one thing I do for getting
those things which are behind and
reaching forth unto those things which
are before I press towards the mark for
the prize of the High Calling of God in
Christ Jesus that's the answer to the
problem
that's the answer
now if we all press towards this High
Mark
well we're not pressed together you will
you cannot do other because who is the
one that everyone is pressing to towards
so can I say because everybody is
setting up their own standard and some
are willing to compromise with the
standards of the world
that we are actually being scattered
whereas if we had this superb standard
in mind
and pressed towards that standard we
would automatically press together
so what is what is this talk all about
isn't that an appeal to the church
definitely especially in the time that
we are living
we have to sometime or another this is
going to have to happen
because we have to go forward and we
have to press through like you said in
the beginning this is the only way that
the loud cry would be able to go forth
we have to get to there so we have to
press towards this Mark for the price of
the High Calling of God in Christ let us
therefore as many as be perfect how do
you achieve that Perfection faith in the
righteousness of Christ be thus minded
and if in anything ye be otherwise
minded God shall reveal even this unto
you in other words there is no other
mind this one or nothing
nevertheless where do we have already
attained let us walk by the same rule
let us mind the same thing but we are in
the privileged position
to be called to be custodians of God's
law
were you called because you were such an
obedient fellow and we're keeping the
law so perfectly was Paul called because
he was keeping the law so perfectly no
he was exercising done
and I'm sure you were and I certainly
was
so if we do not have this mind we will
never be able to press together
all right Martin we can go on and on and
on
I think we must conclude and I think a
good one to conclude with is Jude you
know what I like about Jude
do you know how he begins his his
epistle
he says Jude the servant of Jesus Christ
and brother of James
to them that are Sanctified by God the
father and
preserved in Jesus Christ and called
now who are we talking about here this
is Jude this is the brother of Jesus
he's the half-brother of Jesus
but he doesn't call himself
I am Jude the brother of Jesus he says I
am Jude the servant of Jesus Christ the
brother of James and James was also the
brother of Jesus and he says he's a
servant now if you go to to James just
turn to James
and go to the beginning of James
and read what James says he says James
the servant of God
and of the Lord Jesus Christ to the 12
tribes which are scattered abroad
greeting
Now isn't that amazing isn't that
humility
did James make mistakes oh yes did Peter
make mistakes
did Peter come to the defense of Jude
yes yes interesting right even Paul
when he had he had problems with Mark in
the beginning and Barnabas Barnabas was
angry because Mark was his nephew there
was all sorts of nonsense there but in
the end they pressed together yes and
then Paul went off on his own and he
tried to go there and the Holy Spirit
stopped him and he tried to do anything
he could do nothing
it was fascinating anyway let's end with
Jude
and Jude who says but ye beloved
building up yourselves in The Most Holy
Faith praying in the Holy Ghost keep
yourselves in the love of God looking
for the mercy of our Lord Jesus Christ
unto eternal life
and of some have compassion making a
difference
we need to become a compassionate church
again Martin
we need to care for the downtrodden
we need to care for them that are
bruised and we need to stop being so
high and mighty and thinking that we can
judge everyone
and others save with fear pulling them
out of the fire hating even the garments
spotted by the flesh
in other words you have to be pure
but that doesn't mean you don't get your
hands dirty because if you're going to
pluck someone from the fire could you
get burnt yep I think you could
now unto him that is able to keep you
from falling this must be one of the
most beautiful statements in the Bible
and to present you faultless before the
presence of his glory with exceeding Joy
to the only wise God our savior be glory
and Majesty dominion and power both now
and forever amen isn't this something we
can unify on it's
it's the only thing
it's the unifying Factor right it's what
drove the early church
it is what should drive the Lost church
for sure too let's pray
Heavenly Father
our church is in such a turmoil
and we have to admit Lord that we have
certain
we have compromised with the world
we have joined ecumenical councils
we have run with social issues
we have taken part in parades where the
the foot of someone who has been
separated
should not tread
we have done all of these things
and yet you want to pour out your Holy
Spirit
on all those that have the faith of
Jesus
we have been given a very special
Commission
we have been giving very precise
marching orders
help us Lord to press together
press together to fulfill the commission
so that we can go home is my prayer in
Jesus name amen amen
thank you
[Music]